Season 1 of "Loki" was a mind-bending trip
to the outer reaches of the MCU.
As always, Marvel packed in plenty of Easter
eggs, from obscure '90s product placement
to a ton of fun references to Marvel Comics
and other movies.
Here are some small details you may have missed.
While the Marvel Studios animated logo rolls
at the beginning of Episode 6, we hear Steve
Rogers and Peggy Carter's song "It's Been
a Long, Long Time" play.
As the tune begins, several famous lines uttered
throughout the MCU can be heard.
It's a mixed bag of more than a dozen catchphrases,
punchlines, and tender moments.
We hear Steve Rogers talking to himself in
"Endgame," which is fitting for a "Loki" episode.
"I can do this all day."
"Yeah, I know."
Most of the lines we hear are from major MCU
characters, like the Hulk, addressing Loki
after he tosses him around like a ragdoll:
"Puny God."
But we also hear everyone's favorite Kiwi-accented
rock monster, Korg:
"Hey man.
We're about to jump on that ginormous spaceship.
Wanna come?"
And we get one line from a Disney+ MCU TV
show, and of course it's the one the internet
just couldn't get enough of:
"What is grief, if not love persevering?"
There's some indistinct overlapping chatter
at the end of this opening sound collage,
but a few other familiar voices can be heard
throughout the introduction as well.
As we view the timeline's physical expression,
voiceovers can be heard from several real-life
heroes.
The first comes from Neil Armstrong, saying
"One small step for man..." followed by climate
activist Greta Thunberg shouting, "How dare
they!"
Activist Malala Yousafzai can be heard saying,
"My dream" followed by Nelson Mandela saying
"We have fought for the right to experience
peace."
These real-world quotes are wrapped up with
poet Maya Angelou saying, "I will rise."
In addition to serving as a sweet look back
at the MCU's past, this introduction also
offers a nod to the franchise's rapidly approaching
multiverse.
After all, as the MCU begins to embrace the
concept of countless realities, who's to say
we aren't part of the whole phenomenon?
Slipping a meta brain-bender into the opening
credits — that's so "Loki."
There's a lot to unpack in the first two minutes
of Episode 6.
After "It's Been a Long, Long Time" fades
out, Tchaikovsky's main score from "Swan Lake"
fades in.
The famous ballet centers around Odette and
Odile, two versions of the same character.
Odette is a cursed queen who is forced to
live her life as a swan during the day and
a human at night.
Odile is the opposite in all respects, a bewitching
presence who disguises herself as Odette in
order to trick Prince Siegfried into falling
for her.
In the ballet, the two parts are often played
by the same dancer.
Loki and Sylvie's story is much like that
of "Swan Lake," as it's essentially two versions
of the same character battling one another.
While the ballet ends on a rather happy note,
with Odette and Prince Siegfried coming together
and living happily ever after, we don't go
into Episode 6 expecting happy endings for
Loki or Sylvie anytime soon.
In Episode 5, all signs seemed to be pointing
to the impending appearance of Kang the Conqueror
in the finale.
Episode 6 confirms those suspicions, as Kang
appears in the flesh in the Citadel at the
End of Time.
Jonathan Majors was confirmed to play Kang
in the upcoming "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania"
in 2020, so while his name is never uttered
in "Loki" Episode 6, hardcore MCU fans knew
who he was as soon as he appeared onscreen.
Miss Minutes, meanwhile, introduces him as
He Who Remains, the TVA string-puller our
heroes have been questing for, and a familiar
name in the comics.
Kang's history in the comics is long and rather
confusing, creating countless possibilities
for the MCU.
First appearing in 1964's "The Avengers" #8,
Kang is born Nathaniel Richards and lived
on Earth-6311, an alternate version of the
main Marvel Comics reality, Earth-616.
After discovering time travel, he journeys
to ancient Egypt and becomes Pharaoh Rama-Tut,
but is met with resistance by a time-traveling
Fantastic Four, setting up a long and incredibly
convoluted chain of events that's seen him
battle and ally with numerous Marvel characters
during the ensuing decades.
Kang also has significant ties to Ravonna
in the comics, and with her on the loose as
the "Loki" finale closes, it's hard not to
assume she'll meet up with one of the many
versions of Kang who seem likely to appear
as the MCU's Phase 4 moves forward.
The penultimate episode of "Loki" on Disney+
was a wild, Variant-filled ride that set up
what is sure to be a mind-blowing finale.
It was also jam-packed with fun Easter eggs
for fans to find.
Here are a few you may have missed in Episode
5, "Journey Into Mystery."
At the beginning of Episode 5, we travel through
a destroyed cityscape full of decrepit buildings.
Most of these structures seem like filler
to emphasize the destruction, but there's
one significant Easter egg hidden within the
rubble that's worth noting.
Toward the end of the camera pan, a building
on the right reads "Qeng" — "Q-E-N-G" — at
the top of it.
Marvel Comics fans should know this famous
name as it's related to a major villain who's
set to appear in the MCU.
This tower represents Qeng Enterprises, and
if you thought it looked like the Avengers
Tower, you weren't wrong.
In the comics, it's revealed that Stark Industries
sold the building to the company in "Avengers"
Vol. 6 #0 from 2015.
The CEO of Qeng Industries is Mr. Gryphon,
aka Nathaniel Richards, who exists on Earth-6311
— an alternate version of Earth-616, the
reality where all the main Marvel stuff goes
down.
Nathaniel Richards is also known as Kang the
Conqueror, as the latter was split into two
different versions of himself due to a timestream
error.
It's a complicated story from 2015's "All-New,
All-Different Avengers" #1, but this nod to
Kang — a major villain we know will appear
in "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania" — is
something that we can't ignore.
During Episode 5, one of the first things
we see in the Void is a menacing purple-black
cloud with a monstrous face within it.
"This is The Void.
That's Alioth.
And we're his lunch.
Come on!'
Known as a trans-temporal entity, Alioth doesn't
exist in any reality, but instead what the
comics describe as Temporal Limbo.
The being is the biggest enemy of Kang the
Conqueror, and its empire is bigger than his
foe's.
Alioth first appeared in 1993's "Avengers:
The Terminatrix Objective" #1 and is known
for its absorption powers, which we saw play
a huge role in Episode 5.
Alioth is drawn to living beings more than
anything and has the power [to disintegrate
them as soon as it encompasses them.
In the MCU, it appears as if Alioth lives
within the Void at the end of time, unlike
its location in the comics.
It's also being used to protect the person
or entity behind the Time Keepers, who many
now suspect to be Kang.
If this is the case in the MCU, the two would
be on the same side, a massive shift from
their comic book origins.
In a move we never thought would happen, the
Thanos-Copter became canon in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe thanks to "Loki" Episode 5.
When the Mad Titan finally perished in "Avengers:
Endgame," it looked like we might never see
the famous aircraft, but now, we know why
we never did.
The Thanos-Copter first appeared in 1979's
"Spidey Super Stories" #39 and was a helicopter
the villain used one time to attack Hellcat,
a popular Marvel hero who fought the Titan
as he tried to obtain the Cosmic Cube.
Thanos also picked up Deadpool in the helicopter
in Deadpool Vol. 5 #45, when the latter was
hired to help the Mad Titan steal the cube.
It's such a shame we never got to see that
scene play out on the big screen.
Fortunately, "Loki" Episode 5 paid homage
to a great — and frequently mocked — comic
book moment.
The Thanos-Copter matched its comic book appearance
exactly, with its bright yellow paint and
the Titan's name written across it in large
bold letters.
We knew we'd be getting a version of the trickster
god from the classic "Vote Loki" comic after
he appeared in several trailers for the series.
And he finally arrived in Episode 5 but only
for a brief scene where a scuffle breaks out
between a gaggle of Lokis.
As for the variant's origin story, the four-part
comic series debuted in June 2016 and was
a satire on the United States presidential
election of the same year.
In the fourth and final issue, Loki concedes
the race.
In the comics, Loki's campaign is based on
his honesty about how he's going to lie to
the American public.
The citizens eat it up, except for a reporter
from the Daily Bugle, who's trying her best
to take him down.
It's definitely one of the weirdest Loki stories
of all time, complete with "Political Action
Cults" sacrificing goats.
And we're incredibly glad this dapper and
politically ambitious Loki got to show up
on the screen, even if it was only for a few
minutes.
Just before the Loki group makes their way
down to their secret hideout, we see different
layers of rubble above their little base.
And buried in all this debris, we get a glimpse
of Mjolnir and a small glass jar with "T365"
written on it.
Trapped inside this jar is a tiny version
of Thor ... and one who's a bit more amphibious
than we're used to seeing the God of Thunder.
Known as Throg, this powerful frog version
of Thor first appeared in "Thor" #363, although
#365 is more significant for the character
because it's where he lifted Mjolnir and became
the Thunder Frog officially.
This coincides with Mjolnir being just out
of Throg's reach in the episode, as he's trapped
in the glass jar. "Thor" #365 also heavily
features Loki, who suspects something is afoot
with his brother.
It's a hilarious storyline which includes
Thor helping an army of frogs battle an army
of rats.
Cooper in Episode 1, Episode 5 of "Loki" further
explained some great American mysteries.
The first to appear in "Journey Into Mystery"
was "Polybius" - an arcade game long considered
an urban legend.
The legend of "Polybius" suggests this fictitious
'80s game was real and run by the government
as a psychological experiment.
It was supposedly created to test mind control
on users, but the arcade game was never found.
It looks like it was swooped up by the TVA
and sent to the place where urban legends
go to die.
In the middle of "Episode 5," we also see
the USS Eldridge fall out of the sky and into
the Void.
Unlike "Polybius," the famous naval ship was
an actual thing.
In 1943, it was alleged that the ship was
made invisible as part of the famous Philadelphia
Experiment.
As some claim, it was also apparently teleported
from Philadelphia to Virginia, and back again.
Crew members who were on board reportedly
went insane, and the story was so bizarre
it was adapted into a time-travel movie — "The
Philadelphia Experiment" — in 1984.
Since Episode 5 mostly took place in the Void,
set designers had a major opportunity to include
an incredible amount of Easter eggs from the
MCU's past.
Some of these include "Ant-Man" villain Yellowjacket's
helmet in the first act, which we saw as we
panned over the landscape, and Ronin's Dark
Aster spaceship also makes a brief appearance.
We also get a brief look at a demolished Helicarrier
sitting in the wasteland.
Also, in the vast devastation across "Loki"
Episode 5 is what appears to be a stone face
of the Living Tribunal — which we know isn't
an MCU relic... yet.
One of the most important entities in Marvel
Comics is the character who first appeared
in "Strange Tales" #157 from 1967.
The Living Tribunal basically oversees everything,
ever, in every reality.
Serving as somewhat of a judge of the entire
cosmic universe and all of its realities,
the Tribunal is more powerful than all of
the Infinity Stones combined.
Episode 4 of Loki was the most revealing and
game-changing installment yet.
The episode also had some treats in store
for Marvel Comics fans and MCU diehards.
Here are a few Easter eggs you may have missed
in Loki Episode 4.
One of the biggest surprises to come in Episode
4 is the return of Jaimie Alexander as Lady
Sif.
We hadn't seen the character in the MCU since
2013's "Thor: The Dark World," and while we
suspected the missing hero might be returning,
her appearance was still shocking nonetheless.
Sif's cameo was brief, and those unfamiliar
with Norse mythology might have missed a famous
story hiding in plain sight.
When she first encounters Loki, Sif is holding
a lock of her dark hair.
She charges at Loki, beyond aggravated that
he cut off her tresses, and calls him "pathetic"
and "conniving" in addition to other unpleasant
words.
She aggressively knees and punches him, and
Loki has to relive the event over and over
as he's stuck in a time loop.
While it might seem like a storyline the "Loki"
writers conjured up, they actually pulled
it directly from the two character's mythologies.
In the Norse myths, unlike the MCU, Sif is
known for her long golden hair.
In the myths, Loki cuts off Sif's hair, which
puts Thor — her husband — in a fit of
rage.
After his brother charges him with replacing
her hair, Loki travels to Nidavellir — where
Stormbreaker was forged in Infinity War — so
the dwarves can create new hair for Sif out
of gold which would grow once placed on her
head.
We finally get a look at the Time-Keepers
in Episode 4 after their appearances were
teased with TVA sculptures throughout earlier
episodes of the series.
When Loki and Sylvie are brought before them
to be pruned, the Time-Keepers give them a
chance to speak.
We don't get much out of these mysterious
beings, although their disdain for the Loki
variants is obvious.
With the help of Hunter B-15, who's had her
memories of her pre-TVA life restored by Sylvie,
the Lokis are able to battle and defeat their
captors, and Sylvie severs the head of a Time-Keeper
— only to discover that they're just androids.
Beyond disappointed, Loki and Sylvie are left
wondering who created the TVA.
Marvel Comics might have some answers.
The Time-Keepers first appeared in 1979's
"Thor" #282 and were created by He Who Remains
— someone unmentioned during Episode 4.
Also known as Him Who Remains — or more
simply Him — this mystery being was the
last director of the TVA, who put the Time-Keepers
in place to oversee the organization.
Originally, Him created the Time-Twisters
in 1976's "Thor" #243, another trio of beings
who strayed from their directive and began
destroying Earth every 3000 years.
In "Loki," the time-looping devices used by
the TVA are known as "Time-Twisters," in an
apparent nod to these characters.
"Sorry, the Time Twister just loops you, not
the furniture."
While we don't know who specifically created
the TVA in the world of "Loki," He Who Remains
— or the Time-Twisters — might have some
insight.
Different versions of Loki are teased in Episode
2 during a briefing Mobius gives to a group
of Minutemen and other TVA workers before
they take off to Oshkosh, Wisconsin.
These variants are displayed on a hologram,
which depicts five different versions of the
character.
None of these guys, however, match the four
new Lokis we meet in the Episode 4 mid-credits
scene.
Thanks to the credits, we know these variants
are Boastful Loki, Classic Loki, and Kid Loki.
Oh yeah: There's also a crocodile Loki!
Classic Loki sports the traditional garb the
character wore when he first appeared in 1962's
"Journey Into Mystery" #85.
Kid Loki has a much shorter history in the
comics, first appearing in 2010's "Thor" #617.
This incarnation came about after the original
Loki died, but he was reborn as a child who
eventually joins the Young Avengers.
The backgrounds on our other two variants
are vague, but Boastful Loki's possession
of a hammer could be a nod to 2020's "Thor"
#4.
In this comic, Thor's brother is able to lift
Mjolnir while on Jotunheim.
Loki was also able to lift Mjolnir during
Marvel's AXIS event, when his moral alignment
was reversed, which made him the God of Heroism.
Comic precedents aside, Boastful Loki's appearance
at least hints at some sort of confirmation
that a Loki variant is worthy.
As far as the crocodile goes, there seems
to be no history of this character in the
comics.
We've seen a frog version of Thor before,
a.k.a. Throg the Frog of Thunder, in 2009's
"Lockjaw and the Pet Avengers" #1.
And Loki turns Thor into a frog in "Thor"
#363, so hey, why not a crocodile Loki?
After Loki gets pruned, he winds up in New
York City, where he meets his new variant
buddies.
Most of the focus in this scene is on the
new Lokis, and while your eyes are drawn to
a crocodile wearing gold horns, there's something
major you might have missed in the background.
Avengers Tower — previously known as Stark
Tower — is looming in the distance, absolutely
destroyed.
We've seen the building take a beating before,
but nothing like this.
The new Lokis appear to be hiding out in another
apocalyptic event, although this time, it
seems to have already happened, as opposed
to previous episodes when the events were
imminent.
Avengers Tower is decimated in this timeline,
with its top floor balconies obliterated as
it rests on a tilt.
It looks like the Barn Door Protocol wasn't
installed on this former superhero hangout,
like it was for Avengers HQ in Endgame.
Marvel Studios' "Loki" has introduced a whole
new variant on everyone's favorite god of
mischief.
With the mysterious Sylvie running around
the timeline with Loki in tow, the MCU is
getting weirder than it's ever been before.
Here are the Easter eggs you missed in "Loki"
episode 3.
Much of "Loki" Episode 3 is spent on Lamentis-1,
a rocky, purple-skied moon facing imminent
destruction.
The episode is even named after Lamentis,
which has briefly appeared in Marvel Comics.
Debuting in 2007's "Annihilation: Conquest
Prologue" #1, it lies on the outskirts of
Kree space.
That appearance is basically just a mention,
which means that for all intents and purposes,
Lamentis-1 is basically a blank slate for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe - a perfect
spot for "Loki" to continue delving into its
narrative mysteries, in other words.
Loki and Sylvie arrive on Lamentis-1 after
escaping from Ravonna and her Minutemen following
a skirmish outside the elevator doors leading
to the Time Keepers.
They land on the moon in 2077, 12 hours before
it's set to collide with its planet - an inconvenient
apocalypse for them to hide in, but with their
TemPad low on juice, this odd couple of Lokis
is forced to make the best of a bad situation.
"I'm not the only tech-savvy Loki."
"Don't ever call me that."
"Tech-savvy?"
"No, a Loki."
After Sylvie and Loki sneak on board the shuttle
ferrying ticket-holders off Lamentis-1, they
have time to start getting to know one another
- so naturally, talk turns to their love lives.
Sylvie remains as cagey as ever, but tells
Loki she's managed to keep a long-distance
relationship going with a "postman" as she
runs from one apocalypse to another.
"I've managed to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a postman
whilst running across time from one apocalypse
to another."
At first, this sounds like a joke - as if
she could maintain any kind of relationship
given her current life path - but as it turns
out, there's more than one Postman of note
in Marvel Comics that fans may know about.
First appearing in 2002's "Morlocks" #1, Postman
(a.k.a. David) is a mutant who lost control
of his powers and accidentally wiped his wife's
mind.
He seeks refuge with the Morlocks based in
Chicago and eventually becomes their leader.
Postman ends up losing his mutant abilities
thanks to the Scarlet Witch, whose "No More
Mutants" decree in 2005's "House of M" #7
wipes the mutant gene from the vast majority
of its carriers.
Of course, Sylvie and Postman don't appear
to have a clear connection in the comics,
so we'd say put a pin in this one.
It's not necessarily a hint that the Postman
character is coming, but across the movies
and TV shows of phase 4, the MCU is clearly
setting up something, and it'll be hard to
know what were real hints and what were just
coincidences until the series lays all its
cards on the table.
Multiverse?
Mutants?
Who knows.
Another famous postman is Willie Lumpkin,
the friendly mailman most known for his appearances
in the "Fantastic Four" comic books, and also
for dating May Parker in "The Amazing Spider-Man."
So who knows?
Maybe Sylvie had a thing for him.
There may look like there's a bit of an age
gap, but these are Lokis we're talking about.
Looks can be deceiving.
Or, maybe Sylvie really is just pining for
a hunky delivery man she's never been able
to settle down with.
It wouldn't be the first time an Asgardian
super-being has fallen for a regular Joe or
Jane.
We're treated to some fun callbacks to earlier
MCU chapters in "Loki," and Episode 3 is no
exception.
Once Loki and Sylvie work their way onto the
Lamentis shuttle, they sit and converse in
one of its upper-scale lounges.
As they talk, Loki helps himself to two glasses
of champagne, and Sylvie ends up falling asleep.
When she wakes, her new travel companion has
treated himself to more beverages, and he's
putting on a show for the other travelers
in the lounge.
After singing and giving cheers to Sylvie,
Loki smashes a martini glass and yells "Another!"
"Another!"
Loyal MCU fans will notice this nod to the
first "Thor" film - the line and gesture are
uttered by Thor when he visits a diner with
his new Earth pals Jane Foster, Erik Selvig,
and Darcy Lewis.
"This drink, I like it.
Another!"
The line is one of the most quoted from the
original "Thor" movie, which feels so long
ago at this point.
All of these characters have been through
so much at this point.
It's nice that the MCU can still slow down
and show that it remembers where it came from.
Disney+'s "Loki" is off to a fantastic start,
with the first two episodes positively packed
with fun details and homages for Marvel Comics
fans to find.
Here are some Easter eggs in Episode 2 you
may have missed.
At the beginning of Episode 2, several Minutemen
travel to Oshkosh, Wisconsin, in 1985.
They arrive at a Renaissance Faire where they
believe the Loki variant is hiding out.
At first, it might appear like Oshkosh is
a totally random place for the writers and
producers of "Loki" to select for a scene
like this, but there's actually a sweet story
behind it.
Mark Gruenwald was a prolific Marvel Comics
writer, editor, penciler, and celebrated Marvel
continuity expert, which is why the appearance
of the comic book version of Mobius is based
on Gruenwald, and why Owen Wilson gets to
sport a moustache in the show.
Mobius's appearance isn't the only homage
"Loki" pays to the late comic book legend,
as it turns out he was also born in Oshkosh,
Wisconsin, according to his New York Times
obituary.
Gruenwald died at age 43 following a heart
attack in 1996.
There are hundreds of floors that make up
the TVA, which is full of winding hallways
and curvy architectural designs.
Loki and Mobius take several elevator rides
throughout the first few episodes, traveling
to all different kinds of TVA departments.
In Episode 2, they land on level 372, where
Mobius instructs Loki to read through all
of the variant's paperwork to see if he can
come up with any theories or suggestions.
Why 372?
The Time Variance Authority made its first
appearance in "Thor" volume 1, issue #372.
The use of 372 as one of the floor numbers
in "Loki" is a nice nod to the organization's
origins and suggests viewers should probably
take a second look at all numbers that pop
up in the series.
Loki can only access his own file at the TVA,
so we get to witness Loki read about the events
of Ragnarok, which he hasn't lived through
at this point in time.
While he's looking through the documents,
we see some new tidbits of information about
the event that we witnessed in "Thor: Ragnarok."
The paperwork shows that there were 9,719
casualties in what's described as a Class
Seven Apocalypse.
Mobius confirms that Ragnarok wiped out "most"
of Asgard's people, and we know from "Avengers:
Endgame" that the survivors are currently
living on Earth in New Asgard.
A more light-hearted easter egg hidden in
the Ragnarok paperwork is the mention of the
Revengers.
The makeshift superhero group is assembled
by Thor and includes Valkyrie , the Hulk,
and Loki.
The foursome bond together to escape Sakaar
and are instrumental in the takedown of Hela.
Thor jokes about their group name in the film,
but the group helped save hundreds of Asgardians
from death — justifying their mention on
the document.
In Episode 2, Loki, Mobius, and a team of
Minutemen travel to Alabama in 2050.
They're there to sniff out the missing variant
who Loki suspects is hiding in apocalyptic
events.
The group arrives in a Roxxcart parking lot,
and the store name is too reminiscent of a
famous Marvel Comics corporation to be ignored.
The Roxxon Corporation — which has gone
by many names — is an oil conglomerate that
was first mentioned in 1974's "Captain America"
#180.
Clearly this is the same company now.
Roxxcart has worked with both SHIELD and HYDRA,
but their alliance will always lie with whoever
can fill their pockets the most.
Blinded by dollar signs, Roxxcart deals in
heavily illicit activities, sometimes with
the universe's biggest villains.
In "Thor" #6 Vol. 4, Roxxon worked closely
with Malekith to receive exclusive rights
to mine on any planets he overtook.
In the MCU, the corporation was mentioned
by the Mandarin in "Iron Man 3."
-
"Thomas here is an accountant for the Roxxon
Oil Corporation."
And the brand has been featured in other Marvel
live-action TV projects, including Agents
of S.H.I.E.L.D.
There’s been a long standing rumor that
Lady Loki would make an appearance in Loki,
so when a female antagonist popped up toward
the end of Episode 2, a casual fan and rumor-follower
might just assume that we’ve got ourselves
a Lady Loki!
Well… not so fast my friend.
In the English credits at the end of the episode,
actress Sophia Di Martino is listed as playing
“The Variant”.
However, if you look at the Spanish credits,
Elisa Beuter is credited as playing Sylvie.
That name might ring a bell to long-time Marvel
fans.
It seems likely this Variant is actually Enchantress
- a character who first battled Thor way back
in 1964 in Journey Into Mystery issue 103.
Enchantress’s real name is indeed Sylvie.
Now, we’ve seen the MCU get cute before
with cameos and such - looking at you Wandavision
- so we can’t guarantee you that this is
Enchantress.
Lady Loki still might pop up eventually in
the series, or this is another of those silly
MCU twists Enchantress is the new Lady Loki.
After The Variant sets off multiple reset
charges at Roxxcart in 2050, the sacred timeline
is thrust into chaos.
As Judge Renslayer watches the pandemonium
in her office, her computer screen displays
several locations that appear to be affected
by all of the meddling.
While some of these locations we've seen on
more than one occasion in the MCU — like
Asgard and Vormir — the others we only visited
once.
Hala is the Kree home planet and the one that
Carol Danvers trained on for many years, and
it appeared in "Captain Marvel."
Xandar made its appearance in "Guardians of
the Galaxy," but we know the planet was decimated
by Thanos just before the events of "Avengers:
Infinity War."
In "Thor: Ragnarok," we visited the trash
planet of Sakaar, which the Grandmaster oversees,
while Titan is the home planet of Thanos that
saw an epic battle between the villain and
part of the Avengers in "Infinity War."
Ego is, of course, the living planet, and
the setting for about half of "Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 2."
"Loki" is the third Marvel series to land
on Disney+, and the premiere is just as strange,
if not more, than the frequently mind-bending
"WandaVision."
And, like "WandaVision," there are some fun
Easter eggs tucked away for Marvel fans to
find.
When Episode 1 of "Loki" kicks off, a brief
recap of the events leading up to the series
plays out.
After Loki is captured at the finale of "The
Avengers," we see him escorted by the superhero
team to the bottom floor of Avengers tower.
As we saw in "Avengers: Endgame," a disgruntled
Hulk causes a future Tony Stark to drop a
briefcase containing the Tesseract, which
then bounces in front of Loki's feet.
The trickster grabs the cube and vanishes,
disrupting the entire time heist.
We find out that this portal's other end was
in the Gobi Desert in Mongolia, where Loki
drops out of the sky.
His head sticks out of the sand as he lays
on his back, the desert's landscape partly
covering his green and gold garb.
While it's a brief moment in the episode's
intro, it's also a major callback to the MCU
property that started it all: "Iron Man."
When Tony escapes from his captors in that
film, he flies off into the sky, but he comes
crashing down into the desert sand after his
home-brewed suit malfunctions, breaking apart
into hundreds of pieces and leaving him dazed
on the ground.
The shot with Loki is a nice nod to the first
"Iron Man" and a pleasant parallel that depicts
the aftermath of two men who have just escaped
capture.
After Loki is captured by the TVA, he's taken
to their headquarters.
He signs some paperwork, walks through a temporal
aura detector, and then takes a number as
he waits to see a judge for his crimes against
the timeline.
While waiting, he's treated to an educational
video produced by the TVA to explain to variants
why they've been captured.
Hosted by TVA mascot Miss Minutes, the video
goes into detail about the creation of the
TVA and how the Time Keepers monitor the timestream.
Miss Minutes then explains that when variants
veer off their predetermined course.
"Stepping off your path created a Nexus event,
which left unchecked, could branch off into
madness, leading to another multiversal war."
This isn't the first time we've heard the
word "nexus" in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
— and the last time wasn't long before "Loki":
One of the six "WandaVision" commercials seen
during the series' show-within-a-show is an
advertisement for Nexus antidepressants.
"Nexus: Because the world doesn't revolve
around you.
Or does it?"
Nexus will be a significant word and concept
moving forward in the MCU, as evidenced by
the title of the "Doctor Strange" sequel,
"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness,"
which is being written by "Loki" head writer
Michael Waldron.
In "WandaVision," the Nexus drug was being
advertised as a medicine for Wanda Maximoff's
grief and anger — and also a reference to
her role as a Nexus Being.
"Loki" is poised to further explore what the
term means in the MCU.
When Loki is apprehended in the Gobi Desert,
several TVA officers arrive through a portal
to capture him.
While it's not specifically stated who they
are or what their title is, these guards seem
to be a nod to Marvel Comics' Minutemen based
on their purpose and uniforms.
First appearing in "Fantastic Four" #352,
the Minutemen are charged with policing the
timestream.
As these TVA guards serve the same sort of
purpose, their appearance is a nice Easter
egg.
In the Marvel comics, the Minutemen are actually
robots, not human beings as they appear to
be in "Loki."
However, it should be noted that at the beginning
of Episode 1, a TVA worker asks Loki to clarify
that he is not a "fully robotic being."
"Do a lot of people not know if they're robots?"
It's probably nothing more than a throwaway
gag, but Marvel is nothing if not tricky.
Who knows?
The guards — or Minutemen — could actually
be artificial.
Sure, Owen Wilson's Agent Mobius is a bit
of a time cop, but that's not why he's sporting
that moustache.
In the comics, Agent Mobius' look was based
on the late Mark Gruenwald, a prolific Marvel
comics writer and editor known for being Marvel's
resident continuity expert until his untimely
death at age 43 from a heart attack.
So it makes sense that the live-action Mobius
would keep the 'stache from the comics, and
bring this sweet homage to a Marvel legend
into the MCU.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Loki"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.